how are you doing today sir
Steve it is good to see you how are you
doing excellent I just want to say how
happy I am that the about everything I I
mean that as sincere as I can say it
thank you my friend that means a lot I
appreciate it me too yes I can only
imagine listen I got a lot of questions
for you I'm going to try to do it quick
um anola homes 2 opens the door at the
end for the possibilities of a lot of
different things and I'm just curious
have you guys already talked about a
possible spin-off or do you think
Sherlock will always exist in the Enola
world if you know what I mean
um I do know what you mean yes and I
think I think there's there's so many
options there and the important thing
for me is making sure that I can give
everything I need to give to every one
of the characters that I play and as we
know I'm I'm getting busier and my plate
is becoming slightly more full so I
think it's it's all about making sure
that I have the time to to
to serve the characters as I need to
yeah it has to be weird being it listen
it's you won the actor Lottery you know
you get to do all these different things
I I can't imagine the scheduling
um do you enjoy one of the things I like
about you and Enola is that you're not
the toughest person in the room you can
actually get your ass kicked and I'm
curious for you is it more fun playing
the person who can get their ass kicked
or the one who is kicking ass hey did
they
right this there is something
um novel about being the one who gets
his ass kicked
um it's because there's something to
there's an important piece which you
play to that which is
it it goes in line with being a
supporting actor right as a sporting
actor in this I'm supporting an older
story as a guy who can get his ass
kicked in a room I'm supporting everyone
else's story in that room where if
you're the guy who kicks everyone else's
ass because that's not the truth in real
life you have to rely on everyone else
in the room to sell that as well it
can't just be up to you and so it's it's
novel to be one of the players in
support of that rather than
um relying on everyone else to be the
one selling that you've worked with so
many very talented actors and done so
many different things of all the things
you've worked on what ended up being the
toughest shot that you did on one of
these sets the one that just really you
know what I mean the one whether it be
camera moves whether it be
um whatever it may be that's a that's a
really good question and weirdly I think
even though it's not a single shot it's
a sequence and I love this sequence and
I would do it again in a heartbeat uh
but physically the most enduring
um uh it's so much of an endurance race
was a mission impossible helicopter
sequence
uh because it was so extremely cold
um literally above the Southern Alps in
winter with the doors open on a
helicopter and I'm sticking my face into
the wind and firing blanks with all
sorts of stuff lying back at me and just
doing it over and over and over again
completely deaf just waiting for the
pilot to scream something inaudible and
do this which meant we're rolling and so
I had to then just keep on acting with
my head out the window until I assumed
that they had stopped shooting and so I
would watching either Tom's helicopter
in front or behind and watching the
camera ship as well to see when the
camera ship kind of pulled away and did
its own thing and I was like okay I
think that means I can sit back in now
and I'll do that for 40 minutes then
land and then sit by a little uh like
red rad heater War my hands up and
within half an hour they're like right
we're refueled let's go again and it was
just having to to suck it up and do that
for I think it was
at least two weeks
um but that was that was rough but I
absolutely love the sequence and it was
so worth it there's nothing worse than
spending all of your energy and time and
heart and soul trying to do something
and the other ingredients aren't there
but on a Mission Impossible movie
I mean all the ingredients are there and
so it was such a pleasure to do last
question for you
um obviously I want to ask you about
Superman and I I know you can't talk
about anything coming up because it's
all being figured out but I am curious
what was it like for you putting on the
suit again getting ready to film The
Cameo because the truth is like what
were your emotions because the truth is
it might have been over it might not not
have ever happened again
it was a it was a powerful moment for me
or meaningful moment
um I
I was given a choice of of which which
suit I wanted to wear and and I went
straight for the Man of Steel suit uh
that one holds the most Nostalgia for me
and and the most meaning and to put that
back on
and stand there in front of a mirror
suited up again it's
the suit holds a special power and and
there's no there's no way of getting
around that even if you're the one
wearing it and
to to see myself standing back in that
suit was a is a meaningful moment it's
difficult to describe
um many years hoping planning
striving doing everything I can to to
get back into it and then finally be
able to get back into it uh
it meant a lot and it's something that I
won't quickly forget thank you for your
time and congrats on Enola homes too
it's another really fun movie
thank you very much I'm looking forward
to talking to you in the future
yeah absolutely have a great day